this is one of the reasons I want to
talk to you as I was listening to your
podcast and you have the the thing that
I think is so important which is you
really are curious you really do want to
talk to these people and uh your your
kind of mission statement I think is
let's find Common Ground let's find
stuff that we can talk about
um and I mean I've heard you talk to you
know on your podcast like Lena Dunham
like a celebrity but I've also heard you
talk to people who've done time in
prison people who've been through some
stuff that you know uh maybe a lot of
people don't would never encounter
someone like this and you're talking to
them and you're really listening and
you're really trying to connect and to
me that's what makes it work that's what
makes it really cool thanks man I mean
look I'm I'm I'm so deeply grateful for
the people that come on and and the fact
of the matter is is the vast majority of
the folks that I have come on have never
done anything like this before and I
know I'm asking a lot and almost every
single person that I've had on I have a
very very deep uh a close relationship
with and we have real history with each
other so I understand that I'm asking
them to do something that they're not
entirely comfortable with but I do do
genuinely believe in each person in
their story I think I've just been so
the sort of Kernel of it just came out
of being deeply deeply frustrated with
just the state of of discourse in this
country I felt that um everything is
agenda driven so many of the the major
issues that we talk about are sort of
being led and discussed by people who
have no real experience in that issue
and uh you know it's a big part of it
was coming out of covid you know my
cousin Adam Schlesinger from the band of
uh uh from the band Fountains of Wayne
he he passed really early in covid uh
way too young left two daughters behind
and it really kind of it hit our family
very very quickly and and right off the
bat so we're very serious of source
staying staying isolated up in Ojai and
and and we really weren't leaving for
any reason and then
um you know when George Floyd came
around uh you know in that Uprising
started I really wanted to be a part of
it and and and I saw what happened uh to
Mr Floyd as we all did and um I was
disgusted I was horrified and look I'm
um I'm I'm I'm someone who's who's been
beat up by the police before uh you know
I'm someone who um has a little bit of
experience with that and um I remember
exactly where I was when I saw the
Rodney King tape I remember exactly
where I was when I heard that verdict
and these were sort of key moments in my
life
um so I was out there and I wanted to be
out there
um but at the same time I turn on CNN
and I turn on Fox News and I would see
these protests and I would see people
throwing bottles at police officers and
people Mariah gear and each person under
that mask to me is also a a father a
mother a brother and sister I have
really really good friends in law
enforcement make close lifelong friends
so every time I'd go out I'd also go buy
a district or a police station and show
my resp my support there and it just
seemed like there was this vacuum where
I couldn't be for both things where I
couldn't where you had to pick a side
yeah and for me folks who really walk
the walk they don't just talk about it
they have deep respect and even
reverence for folks that are on the
quote-unquote other side because they're
rubbing elbows with them they're working
with them every day my friends who are
police officers down in Newton have deep
deep respect for the community my
friends who are in the community down in
South Central down in the Pueblos they
see things that police officers do every
day that they have deep respect for of
course there's times where they're
completely on the other side and there's
a lot of anger and there's a lot of
hostility but these people are actually
in the middle of it and my whole idea
was let's bring folks on that walk the
walk don't just talk about it and let's
hear their stories and let's see that
they care about what their kids are
doing they care about their families
they want what's best for this country
too and what I've find is all this
agenda driven were on one side or the
other that's really that's really a
discussion for people
who who don't who have the luxury of
sort of staying in the safe Sidelines
but the folks that are there in the
middle they've got way bigger fish to
fry and again they're constantly looking
for these points of connection and um
it's been um it's been a fascinating
ride we have you know teachers and
surgeons and police officers and inmates
and uh Special Forces soldiers and
nurses and firefighters and um but again
each one of them are people that are
deeply deeply respected from the
community that they're in I think their
story their stories are fascinating and
and and and and most of all
um you know we're really connected
they're people I really really know and
so this sort of leap of faith I'm asking
you to take is that when I say this
person is a you know quote unquote real
one you got to trust me on it well
that's the thing is I've noticed when I
listened to it that uh
that and and this is what I found
compelling sometimes you'd be talking to
somebody and I could tell they had never
they they weren't familiar with
microphone I mean meaning they you know
most everybody I talk to
um knows how to speak into a microphone
not that it's a hard thing to know but
there's a shyness almost that comes when
you're talking to you know a firefighter
or a nurse or or someone who's you know
just come out of prison their approach
to it is not like a like a broadcast or
a performer or someone who's been on a
press junket they're approaching the
microphone sometimes in a little bit of
a different way and they're quieter and
I find that that pulls me in because I
know that what I'm you're capturing uh
an authentic person here and you're not
trying to get them to be something
they're not
um and their motive is not you know
their emotions
yeah and I think it's a it's a very
trepidatious and very I mean a lot of
these folks I mean my one friend who's a
smoke jumper you know a career Forest
firefighter you know we've been talking
for weeks about coming on and look he's
a guy who you know when the forest fires
come up in Ohio you know I fleed from
the forest fires uh fled what is it flee
fled anyway just get your get the [ __ ]
out of here we can all agree that that's
the correct term but that's what you do
that's what one does but he goes right
into it and and was really part of the
reason that kept our town safe from the
Thomas fire but he's very very
trepidatious and worried about coming on
he has something that he wants to say he
wants to talk about the PTSD that's run
rampant and firefighters and that
there's really not been you know we talk
about in soldiers we're starting to talk
about it a lot in law enforcement but
not for these guys and what they see
every single day and that they're sent
right back out to the field and so he
he's got something he wants to share but
uh yeah there's no there's no there's
not a lot of practice there's not a lot
there's there's nothing slick about it
and look it's part of the reason why um
you know we we also make it doubly hard
because there's cameras too and I think
that that's part of the experience you
know really seeing these people open up
seeing what's really important to them
and uh again I just have so much respect
and reverence and and and genuine love
for the for the people that I come that
come on the other thing is
um when you're talking to people like
that the fact that they're not always
eager is assigned to me of also
authenticity because there are so many
people in our culture that are like come
on it's my I want my camera time or I
want my podcast time because I've got a
story to tell and that's fine but
there's so many people out there who
um are incredibly courageous people with
amazing stories to tell and almost their
reticence uh to me makes them uh more
valuable more special somehow because
they're not promoting themselves
um you know
um I've tried many times to go on the
real ones and they've said I've done
nothing Brave no yes I have no John has
said you've done you've exhibited no
bravery and you're not an authentic
person
[Music]
and I said uh you know uh I think I've
you're brave in your your self-promotion
you know yes thank you for shamelessness
yes thank you see and you know what John
that's John that's a form I think that's
what you're missing you know you look at
me and you see a guy who yes flees long
before the fire even broke out yeah it
probably started yeah maybe started it
and also I'm just constantly fleeing in
case there is danger and you're looking
at a guy and you're thinking like yeah
he's not but I think in my Shameless
self-promotion I am a hero oh I didn't
say Heroes outrageous
no one said you know what I think it's
the Eduardo check the microphones
because I sometimes I hear a hero when
someone's saying coward
you would love that you would love it